Now something else that for a Jew this book proves clearly is
That Christ is our High Priest,
A radical change for a Jew,
The High Priest was the man most respected human being on the planet,
Maybe the High Priest Was more respected than the Pope who’s respected today,
Because he every year made an atonement and the atonement of their souls depended on him,
Before God if he had a position of  honor, much honor as Hebrews 4 says.
Now in previous courses of Hebrews we have seen scriptures here in Hebrews
That talk about the High Priesthood of Christ, but I believe that we owe honor to  who deserves honor,
And Brother Juan Carlos, a good student of the Bible,
One time ago shown me that The main revelation of the High Priest in Hebrews
Is ministry on the Day of Atonement( Yom Kippur),
There is no doubt that it is true, it is true and we will study this, we’ll see this during the course
It is a very important key, but that It was a good spark in my heart, thanks to the brother
And I began to see that there is a reason, very important reason
For which  Christ is presented here as the High Priest on the day of atonement
And and we will see it, so that’s the brief introduction.